ở Huế mấy ngày đúng là không ăn chùm một ngày nào nha
mọi người ơi
Cho
con miếng chả nữa nhá
một 8 như thế là bao nhiêu tiền hả cô
dạ vâng Cho con đầy đủ
tối nay là cô ta đã định là đi ăn bún bò Huế rồi
AI dè đến đây hả thằng Tuấn
bánh canh o bướm này siêu siêu đông mà
cô ta đã từng coi quán ở trên TikTok rồi nha
rất là hot
nên là mình đã tấp vào ngay là một tô 10 cẩm UI giồi ôi
siêu siêu to mà á chưa ăn
nhưng cô ta thấy rất lạ một cái đấy là bánh canh ở đây
cái sợi nó nó dệt dẹt nó ngắn như này này
nó chỉ tầm một 2 xăng ti mét thôi
nên là mình sẽ chỉ ăn bằng cái thìa không ăn bằng đũa nha
ta thử nước dùng thì thấy nó kiểu hơi ngọt ngọt
kiểu nó sệt sệt nó ngọt ngọt
nên cô ta đã Cho thêm ớt ở trên bàn rồi
và Huế mấy ngày là cô ta thấy là khẩu vị ở đây
mọi người rất là thích ăn cay
nên là mình cũng đã học Theo
trời ơi 40 cành 8 bánh canh mà mọi người nhìn này
cục chân giò to cỡ này
trong này còn có cả chả cua da heo chân giòn
trứng cút huyết Xin mời cả nhà
thêm thêm với ớt mà đúng ngon đúng hợp luôn ý bảo SAO
ưm ưm
cái sợi bánh canh nó ngắn nó mềm mềm nó hơi dai dai
quyện cùng với cả nước dùng
nó sệt sệt sệt nó hơi ngọt ngọt hơi cay cay
rất là hòa quyện nha
cuốn nha à
thịt đây có thịt mà ban nãy cô ta đã thấy cô Cho thịt vào 8
chính Ra mấy cái món
bún bò Huế rồi cả bánh canh ở Huế rất là nhiều topping luôn
còn sợi bún
hay là sợi bánh canh nó cũng chỉ một phần thôi nha
Cuba Tim xôi thịt nên là rất là mê nhá
ừm chảo cua cái bên chảo cua nó rất là đậm đà ô kê la
đúng là xứng đáng bay vào Huế để ăn à
bọn ta thấy là cô
bỏ hẳn chảo cua
vào bên trong cái nồi bánh canh để nấu cùng Cho nó ngấm
nước dùng ấy bảo SAO rất đậm đà luôn
ừm chân gió quá to mình không biết bắt đầu từ đâu nữa
đồ ăn ở Huế chỉ tầm từ 20 k thôi là mọi người có thể ăn
quán ở Huế rồi
còn topping nhiều không là tùy hưởng mọi người
ăn xong tô này là về yên tâm đi ngủ
thực Ra rất là thích các loại nước dùng ở Huế
hầu như là các món nào mình ăn
nước dùng mình cũng thấy hợp ý
chắc bởi vì là cái vị nó rất là
đậm đà không có Ra là thích ăn đậm đà nha
mà các món ở Huế nhá rất là hay
có giai hay chân giòn ăn nó cứ nhai rộp
rộp rộp rộp trên miệng ý
mình tập cái đường ở bên cạnh ờ đánh cái ô bướm này ấy
không phải mỗi hàng này đông mà
các hàng khác nó cũng đông luôn
nhưng mà ta nghĩ là mọi người đến
là mọi người có thể tiện thử nhiều món ở cái đường này luôn
nói Chung là cứ thấy hàng nào Đông Á là tấp vào liền
người local ăn nhiều á đảm bảo ngon
kinh nghiệm đi ăn ở khu du lịch của chúng ta